foreign
Morocco it's off the map no one would
know about it this was a place where he
could test himself both physically and
mentally with a massive amount of
climbing
and then he wanted to free solo one of
the big walls at the end of the trip
he knew that the route that he'd chosen
would be one of the greatest big wall
free solos in history
I can't wait to sign all this stuff
I'm so curious if we can actually make
these walls feel smaller you know yeah
really cute
Tommy was really the only possible
partner for the training that I was
hoping to do in Morocco
we always like to climb somebody who
climbs so fast it's like so amazing
Tommy's one of the best climbers in the
world
when I started climbing he was already a
hero in the climbing world and I looked
up to him my entire life
Alex and I just felt like if we got
together and climbed we could do stuff
that we couldn't do on our own and from
there it evolved into this very close
friendship
and so knowing that he had this giant
objective my role just became to help
him survive essentially yeah
Tommy didn't want Alex to free solo but
he knew that Alex was going to go do it
anyways so Tommy decides that the best
way that he can support his friend is to
train with him
doing something that dangerous is really
about having full confidence that you
will be successful
Alex wanted to push himself with a huge
endurance challenge
a triple link up
climb three of the biggest walls in
tajia with Tommy in one day
it would be the equivalent of running
three back-to-back marathons
that a world record pace
so what's your guess on time
22 hours
22. I think like 5 a.m Tapas that means
that we'd be doing 21 hour link up
that's my prediction
all right let's see who's closest
okay lap good to go
these big walls are extraordinarily
technical
this is 5 12 513 terrain a rating of
difficulty that really only a
world-class climber can climb
number third and not really loving this
fish
I don't remember this picture at all
foreign
[Music]
I knew Alex was going to free solo one
of the routes we're climbing together
thinking about being up there and out
high off the ground without a rope
that's a terrifying thought
dude
it's so fun climbing like that
pretty solid
is it six and a half
[Music]